les citoyens seraient prêts à payer 100
$ par ménage par année pour réduire
l'utilisation des pesticides
une étude montre qu il y a une réelle
volonté de la population à aider les
producteurs à diminuer l'utilisation des
pesticides
on n'a pas ce soir avec jérôme dupras
qui est titulaire de la chaire de
recherche du canada en économie écologie
jérôme dupras bonsoir bonsoir
alors parlez nous de cette étude que
vous avez dirigé qu'est-ce que vous avez
analysé
quel était son objectif et ce n'était
pas un sondage faut le préciser
non c'est une étude qui a été menée sur
une période de deux ans dans laquelle
nous avons sondé enquêter près de 2000
personnes dans les régions où il ya une
forte vocation agricole et si dans les
dernières deux années nous avons
beaucoup entendu parler des tensions
entourant les enjeux environnementaux en
agriculture notamment sur posant
citoyens aux agriculteurs les lobbys des
congédiements d'agronomes etc
nous on a eu envie de voir est ce que
les citoyens ne serait prêt à
accompagner les agriculteurs dans une
transition écologique dans l'adoption de
plusieurs types de pratiques de gestion
bénéfiques
donc nous avons enquêté ces répondants
sur plusieurs types de pratiques
agroenvironnementales et ce qui est
ressorti c'est une claire préférence
pour les québécoises et québécois à
soutenir les agriculteurs dans une
réduction de leurs usages de pesticides
et donc ils sont prêts si je comprends
bien à payer 100 $ par année pour aider
les agriculteurs à se passer des
pesticides comme on arrive à cette somme
de 100 dollars par année
en fait nous c'était des
une enquête où on leur demandait de
répondre à différents scénarios
aucun des scénarios dans lesquels par
exemple on leur demandait leur le
montant d'une contribution pour un
accompagnement le type de canal travers
lequel s'est fait la durée de
l'engagement et c est donc ce qui est ce
qu'il faut comprendre c'est
qu'actuellement le paysage en
agroenvironnement au québec il ya des
appuis des cadres réglementaires la loi
sur les pesticides le règlement sur les
exploitations agricoles
il ya des soutiens qui sont offertes de
la part des gouvernements de programme
ou un verre le plan pour une agriculture
durable
donc nous nous voulions voir si des
approches complémentaires pourraient
être envisagées des approches
complémentaires construite dessinée à
des échelles plus fine et donc qu'est-ce
qu'on arrivera un résultat réel si on
avait 100 dollars de plus si je me
trompe pas ça fait 180 millions de
dollars de plus par année
est-ce qu'on arriverait à convaincre
accompagner aider les agriculteurs à se
débarrasser des pesticides ou est en
bonne partie considérant que le budget
actuel du gouvernement du québec pour
une transition pour le ou les aides à
l'agroenvironnement en général donc on
est cuit ici biodiversité santé des sols
qualité de l'eau ces deux d'environ 250
millions de dollars c'était 125 millions
jusqu'à l'annoncé l'automne du plan pour
une agriculture durable
donc ces contributions là elles sont
significatives au niveau économique
elles sont significatives au niveau
social également parce que c'est c'est
une forme de main tendue des citoyens
envers les agriculteurs en leur disant
qu'ils sont prêts à voir un canal de
proximité plus grande et l'autre élément
important c'est qu'on vise aussi une
forme de proximité dans notre relation à
l'agriculture ce soit pour les biens
alimentaires ou la qualité de
l'environnement qui émane des pratiques
au chardon qu au delà du 176 millions de
dollars qu'on a trouvé dieu une
opportunité d'intervention dans des
programmes des mécanismes autre qui peut
ici être considéré je pense notamment à
des initiatives qui pourraient être
construites à l'échelle des mrc porté
par des organismes de bassins versants
des fédérations régionales de l'union
des producteurs agricoles donc vraiment
une innovation une créativité et qui est
appelée appelée à se déployer dans
secteur agricole mais est-ce que ça
viendrait cette somme là ces sommes-là
compenser les pertes potentielles
engendrées par l'abandon des pesticides
pour les agriculteurs nous ne sommes pas
allés jusque là dans l'étude de
plusieurs acteurs qui se penche sur
cette question notamment au québec avec
tout le mouvement sur le laboratoire
vivant est ce qu'on doit revenir de ce
qu'il y'a pas une recette unique c'est
pas un programme de gouvernement central
qui dit voici comment ça va se passer
nous ce qu'on propose est ce qu ce qui
ressort de cette étude là c'est que en
fait on peut arriver avec un portrait
plus complémentaires ou des approches
régionales qui vont respecter
l'hétérogénéité de l'agriculture de
chaque région le portrait des
agriculteurs les enjeux environnementaux
le type de cultures les demandes
citoyennes et dans ce cas là on pourra
proposer des initiatives des mécanismes
qui sont beaucoup plus ancrée dans le
territoire
et comme je le disais vont compléter le
paysage réglementaire et le paysage
traditionnel des soutiens actuellement
faire on comprend que les citoyens donc
son prêt en tout cas selon votre étude
selon vos résultats à payer pour qu'on
utilise - ou qu'on utilise plus du tout
les pesticides mais pour les autres
enjeux environnementaux au vote dans vos
études les gens ne sont pas
nécessairement prêts à payer vraiment
plus cher comment vous l'expliquez en
effet les gens se sont montrés prêts à
payer 10 fois moins pour la conservation
des milieux humides et hydriques au
chant et nous avons montré de volonté à
payer pour la conservation des sols le
retour de larmes en milieu agricole ou
l'élargissement de bandes riveraines
donc plusieurs éléments qui peuvent nous
amener à expliquer ces réponses l'a
d'abord c'est que la question des
pesticides a été hautement médiatisé et
qu'elle est très polarisantes et qui a
aussi une faune de on peut rapidement se
symbolise et s'imaginer l'impact des
pesticides sur le
santé humaine la qualité de l'eau donc
c'est normal de vouloir une action plus
rapide
de leur côté les autres pratiques il
faut comprendre qu'elles sont tout aussi
important parce qu'elles vont générer un
ensemble de bénéfices environnementaux
qui impacte aussi notre propre santé la
biodiversité peuvent même participer à
la lutte aux changements climatiques
donc pour aller dans cette direction là
ça nous passe un bon message qu'on doit
sensibiliser sur cette question les
vulgariser est ici demandé un ensemble
d'acteurs que ce soit les agriculteurs
et le leurs accompagnants le
gouvernement les associations citoyennes
est-ce que du pea est ce que l'upm il
reste peu de temps jérôme dupont reste
que l'upm réagi à votre à votre étude
elle réagit j'ai vu ce matin dans un
article dans la presse où on voit ici
que en fait c'est qu'on reconnaît qu'une
demande sociale et on se réjouit de
cette demande sociale pour languereau
environnement est en fait c'est ça vient
souligner la justesse de l'action du
gouvernement du québec à l'automne
dernier avec son plan pour une
agriculture durable parce qu on a doublé
le budget l'agroenvironnement ici on a à
conclure notre entretien c'est que il y
aurait un espace pour en faire encore
plus centriste que l'upr soutien c'est
que oui on ajouter de l'argent mais est
le parfait et les agriculteurs auraient
place un visage est ma plus grand merci
jérôme dupas merci infiniment dans les
soirées pour voir nos émissions en
entier rendez vous sur la chaîne ici et
redit
oh